it is time for audience democracy make a
notepad we have been talking for a while
about this back and forth on live calls
on the show Fridays we take live calls
and we don't screen calls and that's
both good and bad it's good in the sense
that if people want to criticize me or
challenge me they're free to do it
the downside of not screening calls is
that sometimes the call quality is not
as good as some people the audience
would like it to be generally people
seem to either like calls as a good part
of the show or absolutely hate them
there aren't that many people who are
just so taken with the live calls but
there is people that like the calls as a
as one of many show segments and people
who really want them to go we had a
whole discussion and back and forth do
we keep live calls do we shrink them do
we expand them people saying we'll get a
call screener we can't do that right now
the way our system is set up just not
set up to screen calls individually
ahead of time lately I feel like the
calls have been better but overall
there's still some times where it's not
so great and I'm working to improve my
skills at handling the live calls
yeah we've also recently upgraded our
system too so now the questions are less
rambly and I think there's more variety
to the question yeah they have improved
now when you call in you immediately get
a pre-recorded message that says please
get directly to your question and like
have your question written down and so
on and so forth anyway we are going to
combine the decision about whether we do
live calls or end live calls forever
with the patreon fundraiser where we're
trying to get to 2,000 patrons okay this
is the way it's going to work and I
think this has the potential to either
be an incredibly amazing a progressive
media endeavor of democracy and freedom
of choice or something fill in the
blanks or this could backfire horribly
in ways that I could not even predict
ahead of time so here's the way it's
going to work if you want live calls to
stay you make a pledge of any amount
ending in one penny on patreon okay so
you could make a pledge of a dollar and
one cent or two dollars and one cent
doesn't matter right right now there are
no play
that end in one cent so going forward
from this point forward any pledge on
patreon for a dollar Oh 1 201 301
whatever that counts as a vote to
keeping live calls alright the way to do
this is when you go and you go to
patreon.com/scishow you hit the orange
become a patron button and then what you
have to do is you scroll down in the
list of pledge levels all the way to the
bottom where it says custom pledge and
there you type it in could be a dollar
and one cent two dollars and one cent
whatever okay every dot zero one pledge
is a vote for live calls if you don't
want live calls and your pledge in point
zero two you make a pledge of $1.00 in
two cents or two dollars into that sense
or I don't know a thousand dollars and
two cents if you never want to hear live
calls again this is the time to make
your voice heard and if you like the
live calls this is the time to get
active so that we keep it and of course
in the background of all this is that
we're about a hundred and thirty patrons
away from hitting two thousand at which
point and we have really been building
this up I think it's gonna be great I
will be live-streaming
a chess match against a joint producer
team of producer max and producer Pat
who will be playing against me in a game
of chess and to the victor go the spoils
and so on and so forth I don't know
exactly what those spoils will be maybe
like a free membership to an online
chess site or something like that which
I guess I'd be buying for myself so it's
kind of weird but I think people will
enjoy seeing the chess face off so you
want live calls make any pledge ending
in 0.01 at patreon.com slash david
pakman show if you never want more live
calls to be aired again and I know some
of you don't make a pledge ending in
point zero two we will give it what we
give it a week right for the voting yeah
a week sounds good to me you know my
credit limit is five thousand dollars I
mean I asked to get it upgrade to five
thousand and one penny yes that way I
can vote to keep the live calls at the
level of five thousand dollars and one
penny sure hey I like that alright Pat
we'll talk about that after terrible
terrible terrible financial idea but I
appreciate the sentiment okay get the
votes in I
update you later in the week and then
we'll give it a week from today next
Tuesday we will make the announcement